Florida has moved into the number one
spot in the United States for black
owned businesses and number two for
Hispanic and number two for women-owned
businesses what they are saying is look
African Americans and Hispanics are
doing quite well here when it comes to
running their own businesses and being
able to make money here and being able
to live decent lives how do you how do
you address that with this new ban first
of all that's propaganda language over
the last several years it wasn't because
anything he did in policy reality is
propaganda language so there are more
black businesses in Florida than
anywhere second for Hispanics second for
women but that does not matter man you
got scary run to Santa's and we're gonna
scare the hell out of everybody
it's such abject nonsense the chairman
of the NAACP board of directors his name
is Leon Russell guess where he lives
Tampa Florida